[Musik]
dabei ist luca und herzlich willkommen
wir heute einen blog meine termine wie
du es ist ein wunderschöner tag die welt
schon die sonne scheint hat christ und
da heute so wunderschönes wetter ist man
lieben damen und herren asse schon da es
wunderschön das wetter hier liegt ein
kissen am fenster ich weiß nicht warum
ein taschentuch auf jeden fall wird die
rasselbande jude christ und lugano
erstmal zum strand laufen was ich
eigentlich kartoffelsalat mit speck klar
dass sonnenbrand led die das foto eine
spielrunde volleyball
[Musik]
sagen wollte wir suchen uns rüstige jude
law sondern endlich ein gang wenn die
künftigen aufgaben und da sowas
passieren darf er gehen wir gleich mehr
ins gewissen
ich habe es anfragen gesonnen waren
leute kennt ihr noch dieses getränk aus
der kindheit kennt ihr das überhaupt
google kann das einfach nicht aber
durstlöscher
das placement
[Musik]
pure genommen wieder sie zu hause
angekommen wir haben geduscht achten
habe ich nichts gegen sonnenbrand und
meine augen sind auch mal so heftig rot
wenn ich im salzwasser war ich bin
gesund nur mein kopf brennt hat wie
scheisse scheisse ist aber auch egal
freunde denn hier sieht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet ich zeige euch heute
reagiere heute auch komplett bescheuert
jodel sprüche bilder stories witze etc
den hat mir nämlich welche rausgesucht
die ich noch nicht gesehen habe und die
werde ich mir jetzt zusammen mit euch
zum ersten mal anschauen so vier stunden
schlaf am tag reichen mir eigentlich
aber nachts brauche ich mindestens das
doppelte
das ist so ein richtiges julio de spruch
du deine mutter hat mich panisch anrufen
dass ich sofort nach hause kommen müsste
ich fahre eine stunde nach hause und was
ist da die zeit mir einen gutschein fürs
spülmaschine ausräumen den ich vor 15
jahren geschenkt habe ich habe vom feld
meiner mutter hat früher immer massage
gutscheine geschenkt weil ich nie bock
aus spülmaschinen krams hatte richtig
nach gras nähe und ich auch nicht
zweifelt mir der bahn die nach ras auto
kaputt kind fünf jahre alte warum kaufst
du dir kein neues ich dir hier denn das
kostet viel geld das habe ich nicht
damit einfach das kind dann solltest du
mal arbeiten gehen und nicht immer nur
in die kita nun schmunzelt du die ganze
zeit desto bringt echt leid dass ich
hier außerdem so eine tomate aber ich
bin einfach eine tomate und tomaten sind
lecker also nur hält habe gerade bei
instagram einstige posten jetzt habe ich
4 verlor weniger okay leute die
botschaft des angebots
an der stelle schaut carola schöne grüße
an dich glauben er war von dir aussteigt
wird 2 beta gardinenstange in den bus
money ist das jetzt ein neuer verrückt
der trend dass man sich seine eigene
standort festhalten mich weil ich
wirklich in die busfahrer bier talk es
gibt entweder die leute die bewusst von
monatlich mehr bahn fahren und ich war
immer der der bahn gefahren ist auch in
köln so wir haben wir dann essen über
system was eigentlich recht gut ist wo
du wirklich alle zwei minuten irgendwo
hälst aber ich bin nie bus gefahren weil
du hast du immer stand seit der bus oder
bahn schmerzen konnte eine ober dem geld
ein steckt als red cocks wäre nicht
alles auf einmal behalten ist für dich
wenn du mehr braucht jetzt wirklich
jedes mal so der unterschied zwischen
männern und frauen denn eine frau sagte
riecht mal dann liegt das meistens gut
mädels auf festivals ja ja das stimmt
warum gibt es eigentlich so viele
zahnpasta images melder abend mit den
jungs haha da muss es doch ich denke
dass er sehr lustig mutter mit kind
bezahlt den sprit die kassiererin gibt
dem kleinen mädchen lonnie die mutter
sagt und hast du nicht vergessen was zu
sagen das mädchen stimmt noch 1 0 lief
immer intruder bitte wird meine
schwester lee für mich tun habe gestern
einen kleinen freund der grundschüler
erste klassen spaßeshalber gefragt warum
er wie ich keine freundin hat es liegt
nicht am grund der markt ist schlecht
ich bin der beziehung am samstag ein
mädchen kennengelernt sie meinte sie
ruft mich direkt nach der arbeit an mit
die arme arbeitet jetzt schon 72
ja ein herz für für die frau aus keine
ahnung aber ein herz für dich wenn ein
eineiiger zwilling eine
schönheitsoperation machen lässt fällt
es schwer das nicht es höflich zu nehmen
ein grund warum die mannschaft verloren
hatte laut werbung bestücken die spieler
mit heller arno trat der letzte werden
die rezeptur falten geändert es ist aber
wirklich so also ich finds echt komisch
dass eigentlich eine sportgruppe werbung
für nutella macht dieser moment war die
kassiererin bei penny die toblerone vom
laufband nimmt und in die schiene für
die trend liegt aber echt genauso aus
life hält mit der freundin streit
anfangen und auf dem sofa im keller
schlafen
ich hab dich auch letztes vor dass man
bin nach unten gegangen zum schlafen mit
der familie billardspielen gewesen
kleiner bruder was wollt ihr trinken ich
eine freundin die tor fünf minuten
später wieder hier abitur haben sie
nicht erst so richtig kleinkinder dieser
solche sache nicht verstehen ich habe
auch beige früher immer wirklich bsc h
geschrieben
früher heißt bis vor zwei jahren ca ich
denke manchmal leuten aus dem fahrenden
auto zu damit die sich freuen oder den
ganzen tag fragen wer war's das könnte
auch richtig jude sein aber juli guckt
die leute über verrückt oder böse an und
jude meistern das ist bei jedem lied
auslöst weil wenn man dann im staubigen
oder leute böse anguckt und die dann
noch mal meinen vorbeifahren und ich
werde darüber in beim
reißverschlussverfahren nicht
reingelassen weil die leute sagen guckt
jetzt hat ein doppel der in meinen
kollegen und seiner neuen ersten
freundin gehabt seine freunde und ich
nehme die halbe portion ich muss ein
bisschen abnehmen kollege höchstens drei
kilo und das hat man bösen das solltest
du nicht sagen allerdings war das auch
der letzte jude jude hat hier 18 19
stücke ausgesucht
wenn ihr die leute die leute jodel
lustig fanden dann lassen live als die
nicht nötig
dann schreibt die kommentare was
überhaupt lustig findet findet überhaupt
das lustig oder gar nix zu lachen im
leben spaß es ist tatsächlich gerade
21.30 und wir müssen schauen ob wir auf
dieser drecks insel jetzt auch irgendwo
was zu essen bekommen denn alle
restaurant schließen irgendwie um 9 bzw
küche macht dazu warum hängen ja
eigentlich affen in der luft etf mama
ich hab mich auch wenn man verletzt ist
gefragt ich komme hier hoch und ich sehe
dieses buch sag beim abschied leise
blödmann mama warum liest du so was und
warum sagt man beim abschied blödmann
schule das machst du sehr sehr gut und
ich sind süchtig nach diesem spiel ich
weiß nicht wie es heißt soll jetzt auch
keine werbung dafür seien aber ich liebe
diese art von spielen simpel gemacht wie
tapas essen
juli
wirklich
juli werden alle stimmten die scheiße
heute demonstriert zu essen wir haben
locken abschuss dem motto regierung
besteht auf rosmarin kartoffeln dieser
männer staffel wir sind wieder zu hause
angekommen vom abendessen damen und
herren wir haben uns viel zu viel
bestellt aber wir haben es halt ein
packen lassen und jetzt haben wir noch
eine menge rosmarinkartoffeln und
kartoffelecken darum liegen auf jeden
fall wollte ich doch zwei sachen ganz
kurz sagen geben und zwar erstens tut es
mir leid dass der letzte block gestern
kamen und nicht vorgestern aber ich hab
es zeitlich nicht geschafft und jetzt
sind wir wieder im zwei tages rhythmus
drin
die zweite sache die ich noch so
antworte freunde als wäre es dann
wiedergekommen sind hab ich halt die
video gemacht hier vor der haustür wo
ich das video geteilt habe was er
gestern gesehen habt also wie julius bär
ist bei minecraft gespielt da sind
zombie juli
da konnten sondern schlage sehr gut juli
sehr gut und noch mal und war am 1 juli
schneller du musst die ganze zeit rücken
genau wie bei ford bringt dich auf jeden
fall habe ich meine insel mystery dann
ein video gepostet wie ich halt das
video von morton wollte und einem
volkslauf instagram
ich will gar nicht lange drum rum lager
anfreunden schaut euch einfach mal
dieses video an und sagt mir ob ihr
dabei irgendetwas verdächtiges findet
und entdeckt auf einem kanal neues video
online das bisher vergessen zu teilen
und das ist eine ganze hab ich selbst so
schön aber im nächsten video könnt ihr
habt ihr das gesehen und das ist wenn du
dazu habe ich selbst so hoch geklettert
während des videos achtet mal hier
freude da kommt einfach jetzt eine
spinne an und krabbelt auf gewalt hatte
nicht genug kraft nämlich das noch in
die story gepackt sorry an alle die
angst vor spinnen haben das waren auf
jeden fall die beiden sachen die ich
noch kurz sagen heute und ich habe mich
erst mal komplett auf den ganzen körper
mit dieser stimme gesucht allerdings
dieser heutige flocken gefallen hat dann
das gerne
leichter freunde kennen überhaupt freut
ihr euch über models überhaupt möglich
das ist nicht bezahlt und werbung für
juni aber ich mag die plattform aber
sonst nicht seiten sehen während über
ermorden
[Musik]